welcome to the show everybody um they're
they're doing it they've done it they
are actually voting for the government
to shut down
and for the united states to default on
its debt and for the paychecks to start
being withheld from so many government
workers um i'm talking about republicans
of course
this is not exactly winning this is not
exactly america first
and what we have to remember as we go
through the story and go through the
facts is that they want chaos they are
taking this sort of accelerationist burn
it down approach
um when it comes to democrats currently
having the white house and having the
senate and having the house
let's take a look at what's going on and
of course it's now senate minority
leader mitch mcconnell who is
orchestrating all of it uh mitch
mcconnell's senate republican has voted
for the united states to default on its
debt and for the government to shut down
they're doing it again and we're good
we're gonna look at the history of this
and you will see that this is another
one of those reckless political
footballs but this time only one side is
even playing the game we often talk
about debt and deficit the football is
thrown back and forth democrats and
republicans both play the game
although it's republicans who don't
actually care about debt and deficit um
in this case it's a it's a football that
republicans are only tossing back and
forth between themselves
business insider reporting
senate republicans led by minority
leader mitch mcconnell blocked a measure
on monday evening that would have
averted both a debt default and a
government shutdown bringing the u.s
another step closer to a financial
debacle as republicans escalate their
efforts to derail president joe biden's
domestic agenda
all 50 republican senators voted against
the house approved legislation that
funds the government through december
3rd and suspends the debt ceiling until
the end of next year heightening the
brinksmanship over the federal
government's ability to pay its bills
that has roiled congress for months
the measure also includes 28 billion
dollars in disaster aid funding for
communities ravaged by a recent pair of
hurricanes along with aid to resettle
afghan refugees in the united states the
vote was 48 to 50 and the bill failed to
clear the 60-vote threshold to end
debate known as the filibuster after the
vote majority leader schumer assailed
senate republicans saying they quote
voted to drive our country
straight to a government shutdown and
the first default in the country's
history now do we think the u.s really
is ultimately going to default on its
debt no
no and that's why i actually think
oftentimes i think the adjectives uh and
descriptions um in articles are are very
wrong but brinksmanship sort of is
accurate here um in this particular case
the article notes mcconnell has insisted
since june that republicans will not
sign on to a debt limit hike or an
increase of how much the us government
uh can pay back its bills even as he
said earlier this month it was a
necessary step because america must
never default wait if he said america
must never default why is he voting in
that way now what you have to understand
and remember is that they want chaos
they basically want to at least make it
seem as though they are willing to burn
it down although in the end i don't
believe they are actually willing to do
that they'll blame it on democrats
they'll say oh democrats failed to
negotiate a bipartisan deal
this is often what they do they pulled
it with the biden coveted package even
though with the trump packages it was
like yeah okay can basically do whatever
you want
they are
counting on
i guess
enough republicans and independents
getting upset and saying wow things went
wrong
it must be the party in power to blame
right and the sad part is to a great
degree that's exactly how it might play
out
smart independence would realize this is
republicans sabotaging the economy or at
least coming close to sabotaging the
economy to hurt democrats
it's extraordinarily reckless and it's
all to make joe biden look bad and to
make other democrats look bad mcconnell
is not bluffing
in the sense that he really wants it to
appear as though the us will default on
its debt
ultimately i don't think they will do it
but they want to divert attention away
from the damage done by trump they want
to divert attention away from the fact
that more and more evidence is coming
out
that the you know maybe premeditated is
not an all-encompassing term
but that the january sixth riots at
least
uh connected to
all sorts of different participants in
the republican party who wanted to
create as much chaos as possible when it
came to the election of joe biden
and as i said at the top of the segment
this debt ceiling stuff is really all
republicans like it it's not really a
political football insofar as it's one
side that plays this game
much like with covet stimulus let's talk
covet stimulus first
trump does covet stimulus one
democrats have some comments they have
some slight disagreements they're
worried that the implementation of some
of the programs will essentially be a
slush fund which they were right about
because that's exactly the way it was
but they weren't saying no no no we're
not giving aid because a republican
is in the white house democrats did
covet package one and then they did
covet package two
republicans said this is the patriotic
thing to do this is the right thing to
do some of them were a little concerned
with the exact uh sticker price
joe biden takes over
says well it's time for the third covitz
stimulus we're not out of this thing we
need to do something uh and republicans
all of a sudden say oh this this is too
expensive
and these provisions are giving money to
undocumented immigrants uh the
provisions were no different than the
provisions under uh trump covet package
one and trump coveted package two
and it was republicans who did the 180
based on who was in power go back to
october of 2015. in october of 2015
senate republicans under the leadership
of mitch mcconnell majority leader at
the time voted to suspend the debt
ceiling for two years they they
suspended the debt ceiling september of
2017 senate republicans under the
leadership of the majority leader mitch
mcconnell voted to suspend the debt
ceiling again
that got us to august of 2019 and senate
republicans under the leadership of the
majority leader mitch mcconnell voted to
suspend the debt ceiling for two years
and now in september of 2021
now it's minority leader mitch mcconnell
same situation minority leader mitch
mcconnell
is blocking the democratic majority 50
50 with kamala harris as the
tie-breaking vote um uh
except when you need 60 right but it
isn't technically a democratic majority
now all of a sudden that very same
republican party under the leadership of
the exact same guy mitch mcconnell said
oh no no no no we can't we can't suspend
the debt ceiling we're going to go
forward with default and with a
government shutdown these people are
pathetic they really are and when
democrats and republicans are the same
or basically the same we talk about it
um when they are dramatically different
we talk about it and this is exactly one
of those cases ultimately the debt
ceiling i believe will be raised and the
u.s is not going to default on its debts
eventually but the damage that will be
done getting to that and the
embarrassment that will be will be
suffered getting to that um appears like
it will be pretty significant we talked
yesterday we had two relevant stories
yesterday to what we're going to talk
about now which is firings related to
people who are refusing to get
vaccinated for their jobs as required by
their employers yesterday we had two
stories sort of about this one story
asked
is it time to start firing unvaccinated
employees and mass so to speak that was
one question we talked about yesterday
many of you wrote to me and said yeah it
is
it once once you say those are the rules
you've got to follow through otherwise
these are empty threats it's like the
parent who makes an empty threat to the
kid or i don't know whatever analogy you
want the second question we asked
yesterday in another segment and many of
you wrote in about this one as well is
are some of the people saying they're
going to quit over a vaccine mandate
lying
or exaggerating or maybe even
misunderstanding their own willingness
to quit and they're not really going to
quit they're probably just going to go
and get vaccinated and one of the
examples we had yesterday was
massachusetts state troopers where the
union for the state troopers
said we've gotten dozens and dozens you
know massive dumps of resignation
letters the union said that but state
police human resources said
one one trooper actually resigned now
we'll see how it all shakes out
we now have a couple of additional data
points and it seems as though there are
people willing to quit
but more likely be fired
over not getting vaccinated but
yesterday's assessment that it might
only be half to one percent half of one
to one percent of uh employees at any
given organization may well be right
let's look at a couple of data points
washington post reporting north carolina
hospital system fires
about 175 workers in one of the largest
ever mass terminations due to a vaccine
mandate timothy bella writes a north
carolina based hospital system announced
monday that roughly 175 unvaccinated
employees were fired for failing to
comply with the organization's mandatory
coveted vaccination policy the latest in
a series of health care dismissals we're
going to get to that
novent health said last week that 375
unvaccinated workers across 15 hospitals
and 800 clinics had been suspended for
not getting immunized they were given
five days to comply
novant health spokeswoman megan rivers
tweeted monday that almost 200 of the
suspended workers received their first
dose by friday the hospital confirmed
that the rest of the suspended employees
who did not comply were fired although
the exact number of those dismissed was
not specified
we stand by our decision to make the
vaccine mandatory as we have a
responsibility to protect our patients
visitors and team members regardless of
where they are in our health system
we couldn't be prouder of our team
members who made the choice to receive
the kovid 19 vaccine and remain part of
the team
later the article says the mass
termination of unvaccinated hospital
system employees is among the largest of
its kind to date
more than 150 healthcare workers who
didn't comply with the mandate at
houston methodist which was one of the
first to require the shots
were fired or resigned in june after a
federal judge upheld the policy and
importantly
more than 99 of the system's 35 000
employees followed the program we have a
few other data points here as well
becker's hospital review
put out yesterday
a sort of summary
of departures at 18 different health
systems now departure could be firing or
resignation it could be either
and it includes st luke's university
health network
17 000 employees
about and 150 total refused to get
vaccinated and resigned
that is just under one percent
newark delaware's christiana care fired
about 150
or the equivalent of under 90
full-timers for not complying
uh in new york city new york
presbyterian's 48 000
uh team member system
had fewer than 250
resignation firings that is about half
of one percent right along with our
estimate from yesterday
new hyde park new york's northwell
health had about two dozen leaders
not allowed to continue
we don't know the total number there so
you can go and look at the exact numbers
here but what are we learning so far
first and foremost
it does seem
that
when there's a disproportionate
amount of headlines about
people resigning or people saying fire
me fire me sirs
um that the
real number of people willing to go and
whether it's a resignation or a firing
you know it doesn't really make a
difference it seems that it's about half
of one percent to one percent that's
number one
the second thing here is you know when
it comes to health care systems
um this is not just about the employer
in a vacuum saying you got to be
vaccinated and otherwise you're out with
no real connection to reality
this
clearly also has to do with patients
and
what they should do
is the nurses that don't want to get
vaccinated the administrators that don't
want to impose vaccination if there are
any the doctors that don't want to get
vaccinated they should start their own
clinic they should start their own
hospital
if patients prefer to go and be seen
at a place where the employees nurses
and doctors
might be vaccinated or might not but
it's not required
if that's more appealing
to participants in the health care
marketplace because that's what it is in
the united states
if people would rather go to the place
where maybe the employees and service
providers health providers aren't
vaccinated then that would be a business
open a clinic and say hey
if you want freedom come be seen here
come to our er
we don't make the nurses get vaccinated
we don't make the doctors get vaccinated
if that's a popular idea
in the marketplace of ideas then do it
and it will be very profitable my
prediction is
most people who go to a healthcare
setting want to go somewhere where they
know the people providing care to them
have been vaccinated but this is a great
opportunity to test it what do you think
would happen in that situation let me
know you can find me on twitter at
deepakman
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
the david pakman show does depend on
folks like you to support the program we
have a membership program at
joinpacman.com you get a commercial free
audio and video stream of the show every
day we do an extra members only bonus
show every single day for our members
and you can use the coupon code better21
to sign up today
uh tucker carlson the well-known fox
news propagandist had a very sort of
strange guest on last night and um
during the segment
tucker claimed that there are people
being forced to get fake vaccination
cards
and there are a few things about this
that are ironic see if you can guess
what some of them are i'm going to talk
about them uh after we first look at the
clip take a look at this point if you
haven't gotten the vaccine which is free
and readily available there's a reason
for it you've thought this through and
decided not to you thought that was your
right but people are being forced to
some are being forced to get fake
vaccine cards which is understandable i
think because they feel forward they're
trapped what do they do so there's a few
ironic things there were you able to
spot them all it's quite a few and i'm
going to go through them so first of all
tucker claims to be part of the party of
personal responsibility this is one of
the cat the the uh
it's it's a principle i was going to say
a trope this is one of the stated
principles of the republican party
personal responsibility but he's
completely missing who is actually
responsible for getting a vaccine card
that is fake
it's the person who gets the fake card
that's who's actually responsible for
that um it's not whoever uh whatever
employer says hey we've decided you've
got to be vaccinated to work here they
are not responsible for you getting a
fake vaccine card you are responsible
party of personal responsibility
supposedly but blaming everybody but the
person doing the actual illegal thing
second no one is even really being
forced to be vaccinated never mind get a
fake vaccine card and what i mean by
that is of course there are
organizations and companies that are now
requiring employees to be vaccinated
period some of them are just saying
you've just got to be vaccinated like
the hospital systems we talked about
earlier
there are some organizations that are
saying you've got to be vaccinated or
you have to test weekly or you've got to
test daily
but in all cases you as a free
individual in our magical country of
america with the marketplace of this and
the marketplace of that and the job
market
you can decide
as an individual
i can choose
to meet the requirements of my employer
and stay working here or
i can quit and or get fired and go find
a different job and of course as an
individual who
defends the freedom of corporations to
be unregulated and do what's best for
them you couldn't possibly oppose that
right those are your principles no but
they oppose it all the time but you get
to decide
and then thirdly and i'm guessing some
of you knew that i would eventually get
to this
tucker works for a company with a
vaccine passport system
and a stricter vaccination policy than
the one that joe biden announced a few
weeks ago
and tucker hasn't complained about it
once on either of his programs on his
nighttime program nor on his daytime
program and as a reminder a few weeks
ago joe biden came out and said
uh we are putting in place a requirement
for employers with at least 100
employees
where the employees either must be
vaccinated or they've got a test weekly
that was what joe biden put in place
fox news has a far stricter policy the
fox policy is you've got to be
vaccinated and submit proof of
vaccination through our vaccine passport
system
if you're not vaccinated you have to
test daily remember biden's plan biden's
program is weekly fox says we're going
beyond it we're saying if you're not
vaccinated you need a daily test
and you need to continue wearing masks
in many settings where a vaccinated
individual would not have to wear a mask
okay
tucker hasn't mentioned it once tucker
hasn't said hey by the way guys you know
all these segments i'm doing about how
terrible all of these requirements are
fox's requirements my employer has even
stricter requirements and i denounce it
he hasn't said it once shocking right
given how principal tucker carlson is oh
no of course not uh because it's all
grift to the degree that i would assume
tucker is vaccinated and i would assume
that much like we'll get to later based
on what people have said tucker knows
that this is a way to get good ratings
by making people angry and afraid
so saying that someone is forced to get
a fake vaccine card because they don't
want a vaccination is like saying
i don't know i i was forced to rob a
bank because my employer doesn't pay me
enough money really
and sadly
this perverse logic
is sometimes used to justify violent and
horrible actions
we were
driven to riot
because they stole the election from
trump we had we had to do it
well hold on a second what happened to
personal responsibility
we were driven to loot and to destroy
property
because they came out and protested for
better policing which we don't think we
need what see how that goes they were
forced to be criminals
and yet
they claim to believe in personal
responsibility bottom line remember
tucker is giving his audience the pablum
that they want and that is really
profitable for him tucker is almost
certainly vaccinated he's almost
certainly in favor of vaccines he's not
offended enough about vaccine
requirements to even mention the fact
that his employer has one of the
strictest ones and there's a very good
article from the washington post called
tucker carlson ties his vaccine
fear-mongering to a core republican
insecurity philip bump wrote this and he
tried to explain this as follows quote
he's enormously skilled tucker at
elevating fear among his viewers at
presenting them a sensible line of
defense against an irrational and
devious world so he wraps the effort to
vaccinate americans into a broad sense
that america is changing in ways that
undercut its traditions imagine treating
a vaccine as a god which of course no
one does
fox news obviously sees value and
amplifying republican concerns about the
vaccine if it didn't it's safe to assume
that it's programming including
carlson's would be redirected
fox news employees who spoke with the
daily beast described the network's
focus on undercutting the vaccine or at
least government advocacy of it as quote
great for ratings and something that is
unparalleled in getting quote our
viewers more excited or engaged they are
admitting
why they are doing this
lastly philip bump writes fear and fury
are great motivators and if you can make
vaccinations seem like part of a
government-promoted effort to push
americans away from religion all the
better this is the game that he's
playing and he's playing it quite well
let's look at a very interesting segment
from fox news yesterday
this is a segment in which um jesse
waters
i believe is the host of this program
uh this right winger who's very popular
on social media one of the top view
getters on facebook
dan bongino
is a guest or panelist
and the topic is crime in the united
states this is a favorite topic right
now of the right to lie about and to
deceive people about uh on right-wing
media and fox um i guess she's like a
contributor she's a guest on this
program fox contributor jessica tarlov
absolutely crushes waters
and bongino
um now i don't i jessica tarlov may be a
centrist i don't know that much about
her i'm not calling her a hero i'm not
saying anything other than
in this particular segment she's really
really good at crushing the dishonest
delusional lies
of two of these guys on fox news so
let's look at the segment again the
framing here is
the crime surge
which republicans are attributing to joe
biden
but they're using 2020 data
to attribute it to joe biden now you
might be saying hold on david
trump was president in 2020. how does
that have to do with joe biden and that
is exactly the right question so let's
take a look at the segment
and the spike in murders again was only
in areas dominated by liberal
politicians so this is obviously not
true it's obviously has something to do
with the politics not kovan so the
framing there is
we're going to talk about the fact that
the crime is up in cities
rather than the fact that the crime was
up while trump was president but of
course we've talked before
cities tend to be run by democrats quote
dangerous cities are run by democrats
and safe cities are run by democrats
because in general democrats prefer
cities and republicans prefer non-cities
okay let's see how jessica tarlov deals
with this i'm not sure that it has
something to do necessarily with the
politics there are a few things that are
important here one jesse we'll do
another segment on that but all those
countries you read they don't have a
rampant gun problem like the united
states of america does check how many
weapons people can still kill you with a
knife go down but they're not they're
they're not enough to colombia i lived
in the uk a long time where people got
knifed all the time and it's still
nothing close to our murder rates okay
this is a this is they love this talking
point but it's very dumb
knives create less death than guns in
equivalent situations part of it is to
kill someone with a knife there's
something much more
sometimes viscerally repelling i mean
the action right of stabbing someone to
death you've got to be people aren't
throwing knives from across the room
you've got to be right on someone and
the fact that with a gun you can create
more distance and still inflict damage
to someone
just makes it less likely that a mass
stabbing would even be attempted in the
same way that the mass shooting would be
but we have data about mass stabbings
and most people survive one of the most
deadly mass stabbings we covered it at
the time it was in 2019 in japan two
people were tragically killed two kids
17 were injured and survived someone
with a semi-automatic weapon in that
situation with the amount of time that
this incident lasted
would almost certainly kill many many
more people so good that good for
jessica tarlov for pointing that out
jesse waters is going to say people can
be killed by knives fine it may not
convince that many people on fox news
but jessica tarlov is getting it right
now let's get to the 2020 thing which is
just unbelievably dumb that they're
doing the data that we're talking about
is 2020 those were the trump years so
all of this blaming on president biden
that's happening now actually under
president biden's watch the murder rate
has even gone down another important
component of the fbi data that the
short-term increases was in all regions
not just in those liberal cities all
regions that means in places where
conservatives are that means that this
can all be because of bail reform to
fund the police yada yada yada and also
the murder rate and the crime rate
overall is lower than it was in the
1990s so conservatives are running
around screaming we've never seen
anything like this you have seen
something like that so these are all
very good points and they all should be
dealt with individually
if the problem is that the the danger
and crime
are happening in liberal cities we need
to adjust for the fact that liberals
tend to live in cities and run cities
and conservatives tend to overall live
in more rural and suburban areas and in
terms of per capita crime rates
uh we actually see that per capita some
of those rural areas are really really
dangerous the problem is it's hard to
compare a city to a tiny town you have
you have really have to look at an area
where you have enough of a population to
actually evaluate this uh and then of
course number two
long term the crime rate has been going
down we did see a bump in 2020 but trump
was president and much of it was despair
related to the mishandled pandemic they
were blaming biden back then
saying well it's the culture of people
who would vote for biden combined with
people saying we should defund the
police even though it hadn't actually
been done it had just been proposed by
some
uh but i thought the buck stopped with
trump or whoever was president so this
is a really great example of
the narratives that they push
not having anything to do with the facts
and a sensible person in this case
jessica tarlov just saying hold on let's
put some facts in the way of the
propaganda how many fox viewers were
convinced by this i have no idea maybe
not many
but this is exactly the way that if
you're going to participate and jessica
tarlov is a contributor to fox so
clearly she is if you're going to
participate in these setup
uh uh debates that are set up against
you this is exactly the way to do it
we'll have more on this on the david
pakman show instagram which you can find
at davidpakmanshow you can also find me
on instagram david.pakman
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow all right i got a bunch
of emails from folks over the last 24
hours about this new book coming out
from the very short-lived white house
press secretary stephanie grisham who
worked for donald trump for a little bit
she has written a new book and some of
the allegations in the book are just
absolutely crazy we're going to talk
about them uh each is crazier than the
last or the previous or whatever sort of
a phraseology you want to use
let's start with uh this first one about
donald trump having
what's being described as a surgical
procedure i'm going to talk about this
in a second
and opting not to receive anesthesia
because if he had received anesthesia he
would have had to temporarily turn over
presidential powers to the vice
president mike pence this happened when
george w bush had i believe it was also
a colonoscopy back during his presidency
and dick cheney was briefly uh
temporarily given presidential power so
the story is trump skipped anesthesia
for a previously unreported procedure at
walter reed to avoid giving pence
temporary power
um the details are
that trump skipped anesthesia for a
previously unreported colonoscopy in
2019 so he wouldn't have to temporarily
relinquish presidential powers this is
according to a new book called i'll take
your questions now
stephanie grisham wrote it former white
house press secretary and chief of staff
to melania trump
she said in the book that this was for a
regular colonoscopy now let's talk about
that a little bit
the initial story was wow
trump's pretty alpha i mean he's saying
do the opera do the surgery
without anesthesia that is that is wild
then it came out it's a colonoscopy so
you might be asking is it accurate to
say that it is surgery is a colonoscopy
really surgery
it is classified as a minor surgical
procedure
uh sometimes they're just taking a look
sometimes if there's a polyp or
something
then they are cutting something out and
then it's you know more more clearly a
surgical procedure
um it is generally done with anesthesia
often it's like a deep sedation you're
not like out like i was for my famous
appendectomy
but you are um you are sedated
uh but it is one of the things that that
is done without anesthesia and some say
that it is safer
without a general sedation i i you know
i'm not a medical expert i don't know
exactly that but it's the patient's
choice
and sometimes patients don't realize
they have that choice um but it is not
inaccurate to call it a surgery in the
sense that that is how it is classified
so the article goes on to say
trump puzzled reporters with a
mysterious unscheduled november 2019
visit to walter reed you might remember
this is that infamous why did he go to
walter reed and added to the confusion
by saying it was part of his routine
annual physical for 2020. remember he
said i was just hanging out
and i thought i'd go and get it get a
jump in 2019 on my 2020 physical that
was a lie we believed it to be a lie at
the time and it was and it was for a
colonoscopy but the big news is that
um
he
according to stephanie grisham
opted not to receive the general
anesthesia
in order
to
maintain presidential power and not have
to relinquish it to vice president mike
pence
uh grisham wrote in the book
trump could have used the procedure to
spread awareness and educate americans
about the importance of colonoscopies
but as with covet he was too wrapped up
in his own ego and his own delusions
about invincibility
and he quote didn't want to be the butt
of a joke
how immature do you have to be as a 70
plus year old man so first of all
there's
the the the desire to keep power
and maybe trump was imagining
if pence were president and i was the vp
i would be using this opportunity
to try to somehow seize the power of the
presidency when the president is being
sedated for a colonoscopy so maybe
trump's idea of i don't want to give it
up to pence was rooted in if i were
pence i'd be trying to seize power we we
don't know but that certainly tracks
with donald trump but then the other
part of this is
you know the idea that you're going to
be laughed at because you got a
colonoscopy in your 70s rather than hey
you know what this is a great
opportunity to talk about the importance
of routine screenings and colonoscopy
being a part of that but no that's not
the way that trump functions so it all
tracks here
and
for me the bigger story is with this
stephanie grisham book and we're going
to get in a moment to more of what she
writes in the book
this is another person stephanie grisham
who was in trump's inner circle had a
front row seat to what was going on who
saw the reckless dangerous and petty
behavior that donald trump was engaged
in
did nothing said nothing at the time
and later is speaking out about it now
when there's an opportunity to make
money from it from writing a book that
should come as no surprise either
because trump was surrounded by these
people but it is yet another despicable
action by one of these folks let's now
talk about the next story from stephanie
grisham's new book okay so one story
from stephanie grisham's new book i'll
take your questions now
uh is
trump opted not to receive uh anesthesia
general anesthesia or deep sedation for
his colonoscopy in 2019 because he
didn't want to temporarily give
presidential power to mike pence okay
that's story number one
the second story told by stephanie
grisham which we're going to look at now
is i believe far more disturbing because
it again is more of a another data point
in this
smitten-ness i don't know that's a word
and trump being smitten
with authoritarians like vladimir putin
stephanie grisham writes in her new book
that donald trump told putin privately
i'm gonna have to act a little tougher
to you in public
for the cameras okay
uh salons john skolnick wrote about this
yesterday
donald trump reportedly assured vladimir
putin that he had to act quote a little
tougher next to the russian president
quote for the cameras according to a
forthcoming book by trump's white house
press secretary the book i'll take your
questions now by stephanie grisham
details a host of never-before-seen
insights into trump's relationship with
putin brings to light a number of more
bizarre personal requests his terrifying
temper and strains in his relationship
with the former first lady melania trump
according to the new york times the
former president went out of his way to
please putin telling the russian leader
during the 2019 osaka summit the g20
that he would put on a display of
machismo but just for show
trump reportedly told putin with all the
talk of sanctions against russia for
interfering in the 2016 election and for
various human rights abuses i'm gonna
act a little tougher with you for a few
minutes but it's for the cameras and
after they leave we'll talk
you understand
in another instance grisham also claims
trump joked with putin about quote
getting rid of journalists who produce
quote fake news
telling him you don't have this problem
in russia
wow
the washington post got a copy of the
book
it details tensions between trump and
his wife melania who quote unleashed her
contempt for her husband amid reports
that his attorney michael cohen paid
adult film star stormy daniels to keep
quiet about their affair it was during
this personal debacle that melania
reportedly grew much closer with grisham
telling her that she didn't believe her
husband's denials of the affair oh
please are you kidding me i don't
believe any of that
this is the equivalent so i don't care
about the melania stuff trump
saying to putin i'm gonna have to
pretend to be a little tougher with you
for the cameras but we're gonna talk
everything's fine
this is the equivalent of bombing syria
bombing syria
but telling putin ahead of time
and bombing an empty runway which was
back up and running within hours now i
was not for the escalation of tensions
with syria i don't mention that anecdote
because i'm saying trump should have
really crushed syria that's not what i'm
saying it's an example of the
subservience of trump to putin it's not
about they were in a room together
plotting this or that we never believed
that that was the case it's not about
the quote collusion with russia was
going to be so proactive that it was
going to remove trump that was never the
case go to my clip say april 2017 where
i'm telling you that
this is about
the
level of again trump being smitten with
people like putin and just enamored
um and sucking up to them
the other funny little detail
is that if this is true if trump did
tell putin i'm gonna have to act tougher
in front of the cameras
but but don't worry it's not gonna be
real trump didn't really act tough with
putin in front of the cameras i think
there was like
you know
i asked him about the hacking
and he said they didn't do it
that's acting tough what are you even
talking about like if that was trump
acting tougher with the cameras on
imagine the level of suck-up
brown-nosing that was taking place
behind the scenes
and it's just become so clear in the
time since trump has left office
that putin and the russians you know
they are really good at this stuff they
really are it's not me
taking a position it's just putin and
the russians know a perfect mark when
they see one and trump is just the
perfect mark
um this shouldn't be surprising to
anybody i saw a funny comment which was
you know we've had more on presidents
before
we've had cowardly presidents before but
a [ __ ] coward
in trump's configuration was really a
unique combination
um
you could say that as far as the grisham
book goes
she she's a disgruntled another
disgruntled former person who you can't
believe anything she says maybe maybe
but that remains to be seen and so far
everything that's been reported as being
in her book from the advanced copies
that the new york times and the
washington post got it all is very very
much on brand we'll take a quick break
when the book is finally out we'll have
much more from it i'm sure
follow the david pakman show on social
media interact with me and other david
pakman show viewers you'll be able to
see when we're taking calls live on the
show we post hilarious video clips
you'll see exclusive show content not on
the show and you'll be the first to see
big announcements like upcoming guests
and more follow me on twitter at d
pacman and david pakman show we're on
instagram david.pakman join the reddit
community at davidpakman.com
reddit and you can also find the david
pakman show on facebook
discord and tick tock it's almost too
easy
so one of the um 2022 races that we're
following more and more closely is that
of the texas gubernatorial uh race we
believe that uh beto o'rourke is going
to be entering as a democratic
challenger against the incumbent
republican governor greg abbott greg
abbott has been an absolute disaster for
the state of texas he has been
disgusting along with his lieutenant
governor dan patrick since day one of
the pandemic the infamous grandma's
willing to die for the economy uh
incident of course as you might remember
greg abbott has been absolutely horrible
on energy texas of course with this big
boy libertarian independent energy grid
which has failed them in the winter and
it's failed them in the summer and it's
just a disaster for texas and then now
of course recently with texas uh seeing
covid run rampant during the delta spike
this has fortunately really hurt the
approval ratings of greg abbott and we
have additional new data about this more
texas voters now believe that greg
abbott does not deserve re-election and
of course they are completely correct
more texas voters believe greg abbott
does not deserve to be re-elected
according to a poll released yesterday
tuesday the survey was conducted by
quinnipiac university finds that 51
percent of registered voters in texas
believe abbott doesn't deserve
reelection compared with 42 percent who
say he does deserve a third term these
are
disastrous numbers for an incumbent
republican texas governor
and i love it
the opposition to abbott's re-election
is up from june a different quinnipiac
poll in june
found 46
said reelect and 48 said no
now it's only 42 say re-elect 51 say no
basically like a four-point slide
in the direction of bad i should say
from the standpoint of negative uh the
most recent poll also found only for 44
of texans approve of the way abbott is
handling his job as governor 47 now
disapprove
this is the first time since quinnipiac
started polling texas that abbott's
approval rating is below disapproval
referred to as being under water
this is absolutely fantastic now most
republicans still support abbott 83 of
republicans approve
only 12 disapprove
uh as far as independents go 43 percent
approve
only six percent of democrats approve in
texas now just as an example okay of how
absolutely
horrible this guy is
this was um over the weekend on fox news
chris wallace really grilling greg
abbott over his claim that listen we
don't have to worry about the abortion
law the dystopian abortion law that we
passed
restricting the
ability
of women who have been raped from
obtaining abortions we don't have to
worry about that because we're going to
eliminate rapists
ban the virus right i mean just make
murder illegal solve the problem okay
let's listen
is it
reasonable to say to somebody who was
the victim of rape and might not
understand that they are
pregnant uh
you know until six weeks well don't
worry about it because we're going to
eliminate rape
as a problem in the state of texas it
doesn't make sense no but let's see what
he says
well there's multiple things i have to
say in answer to this but the first
thing obviously uh is that survivors of
sexual assault
they deserve support care and compassion
now it's funny how he says obviously
much of the republican party doesn't
make it obvious actually
and texas is stepping up to make sure
that we provide that by
signing a law and creating in the
governor's office
a sexual assault survivors successful
task force uh but separately from that
chris i gotta point out uh about the
ways that i have fought to
go uh
to arrest and apprehend and uh try to
eliminate rape but i sought the death
penalty but but governor governor excuse
me governor excuse me because we are
running out of time there were more than
15 000 rapes in 2019 when you were
governor yeah apparently just you know
ending rape
uh by threatening people with really
strict punishments you know
he he wanted the death penalty for
rapists we really continue to lack
evidence that the death penalty is
really a deterrent
um
we've studied that for a very very long
time
uh but you know we're gonna eliminate
rape is kind of like ban coronavirus and
just be done with it it doesn't make any
sense and then of course meanwhile
uh the latest is
texas has this disaster with covid
texas has this disaster with energy
and what is abbott doing abbott is
launching voter fraud audits
from the 2020 election
bowing to trump's pressure vanity fair
reporting
greg abbott
is suddenly bending over backward to
find 2020 election fraud
abbott's office says it has been
reviewing votes
in certain texas counties for months
but others say the mad dash only started
after donald trump demanded an audit
uh greg abbott
is going to be
pushing for auditing multiple count
auditing recounting who even knows what
these things mean at this point in time
four counties in texas
trump won texas there is no point we
talked about this on the bonus show
yesterday there is no point to do this
whatsoever
texas is so poorly served greg abbott
lieutenant governor dan patrick remember
the cancun cruz fiasco
it would bring me no greater pleasure
than to see greg abbott just absolutely
crushed
in 2022
and beto o'rourke could be the guy to do
it i don't know i mean coming off of a
loss is never
doesn't put you in a particularly strong
position last week one of our live
callers asked is beto really the right
guy to face off against abbott given
that he lost his last race i don't know
the answer to that
um but we have time
listen matthew mcconaughey matthew
mcconaughey
death depending on your preference beto
o'rourke beto o'rourke whatever
pronunciations you you have for these
folks um they would all be better than
greg abbott for sure and we're going to
follow this race very very closely
so um
we had a call maybe it was last week
maybe the week before
where a viewer asked me what do i think
happened to the whole matt gates thing
the investigation
charges were expected forthcoming etc uh
and i said i don't know
that these things can take a while i
don't you know i said at the time i
don't know if matt gates is going to be
charged it's not looking good but i
don't know if matt gates is going to be
charged the latest news is that matt
gates has hired a bevy
uh of sex crime lawyers to defend him
and
it makes sense that if you expect
charges
of murder you would hire lawyers who are
experts in defending you against murder
charges that sort of is logical that
makes sense and he's entitled to get
lawyers but this is a sign of maybe the
direction that things are going best
levin writing for vanity fair
that the last time we checked in on the
legal comings and goings of matt gates
things were not looking great for him
um since the news broke this spring that
he was under investigation for paying
women for sex and separately for
sleeping with a minor and transporting
her across state lines the hits have
included gates former wing man pleading
guilty and having charges dropped from
33 to 6 in exchange for cooperation that
didn't look great for gates
the news that gates had allegedly paid
the women he compensated through online
payment platforms leaving a digital
paper trail not good
the news that the feds are additionally
looking into obstruction of justice
charges
his former wingman reportedly giving the
feds years of venmo transactions and
thousands of photos and videos and gates
being heckled on the street by strangers
shouting people think you're a pedophile
gates has denied allegations but the
latest news in terms of his lawyers
uh suggests that this could be real
trouble gates has hired a major team of
lawyers the team according to reporter
roger sullenberger
includes attorney mark mukasey who has
defended the trump organization in a
number of legal battles
isabelle kirschner a top criminal
defense lawyer who represented robert
hadden the ex-columbia university
gynecologist accused listen to this
by 200 patients of sexual assault
ultimately pleaded guilty
with regard to two patients lost his
medical license didn't get time in
prison so it seems that isabelle
kirschner is the right person to hire
meanwhile gates's campaign has returned
the service retain the services of new
york trial lawyer mark furnitch who has
the distinction of having defended some
of history's most notorious criminals
including jeffrey epstein
the mexican drug lord joaquin guzman aka
el chapo and keith reneer who was
sentenced to 120 years in prison for
running the nxivm sex cult where women
were branded like physically branded
and forced into sexual slavery all of
this suggests gates is taking the
possibility of winding up in legal
trouble
very very seriously spokesperson for
gates declined to uh declined a request
for comment so there's a lot going on
here all right in the context of are
there ever going to be charges
this signals we should be keeping an eye
on this because there could be charges
very very soon and they could be very
serious charges now here's my view on
the lawyer thing
if you ever need to defend yourself for
any crime you're accused of whether
you're guilty or innocent doesn't matter
whether you're guilty or innocent if
you're accused of a crime you should
hire a lawyer that specializes in
defending people against that type of
crime any sensible person would do that
given reasonable means so matt gates can
hire whoever he wants
this is a signal of what may be coming
and that's it
if i were being criminally tried i would
want a criminal lawyer if the criminal
charges were murder i would want someone
experienced in defending murder there's
no question about it
the fact that he's hiring these people
signals that there are some really
serious charges potentially coming
related to sex crimes doesn't mean he's
guilty he gets his day in court every
time we talk about possible charges
people write to me and they say david
do you not support due process do you
not support innocent until proven guilty
first of all sort of like do i support
gravity it's like we have due process
and people are innocent until proven
guilty he gets his day in court
everybody's entitled to that
but this signals that the charges may
well be coming
however
he really shouldn't be allowed to use
campaign funds for these lawyers because
these are personal charges now there are
people making the the argument
um
that part of this is retaining counsel
for his campaign
so that if there are charges
the campaign for reelection can continue
unfair
it feels pretty weak to me the the
charges are for personal actions and he
should not be allowed to use campaign
funds for his defense
i feel very strongly about that uh the
there's already been reportedly 25 000
for a lawyer been paid by the gates
campaign even though the charges stem
from gates alleged personal actions
that's not good that shouldn't be
allowed but uh let's buckle up
because uh this really could get very
interesting very very quickly we have a
voicemail number if you want to call in
that number is 219
to
david p call anytime
during the trump rally on saturday we
talked about this group blacks for trump
they wear shirts that say blacks for
trump they are black the individuals
mostly and we've talked about how it is
a common thing at trump rallies that the
few black attendees are placed very
conspicuously on stage behind trump
here's a caller who tried to figure out
who who are blacks for trump and he
didn't come up with much take a listen
hi mr pacman my name is alfredo gomez
follows and i
was watching her show and i just had a
question for you
like you showed this video of trump just
recently in a rally
this is today's 9 27 2021 and there's a
bunch of people that have blacks for
trump t-shirts that are in white with
black letters and they're black people
and i was just wondering if you could
give us a take on that why is that
happening i looked up
blacksfortrumps.com nothing
uh i looked up blacks for trump's really
i don't see anything so i was just
wondering
if maybe you could enlighten us on some
of that i love watching your show and
remember
and
thank you so much for
putting the word out there the reality
thank you so listen um i've been
treading a little bit carefully about
the blacks for trump thing because uh
if you do a search for blacks for trump
you will find a lot of articles about
one of the individuals involved with
blacks for trump
but there's very little about this
supposed group and i don't want to you
know it it feels wrong to me and
disqualifying
to just basically say
if there are black people at a trump
rally clearly it's astro turf or or
they've been paid
i i don't have evidence of that the fact
that there's so little about blacks for
trump as a standalone group with
anything other than just appearing at
rallies in part of their sort of
repertoire makes me wonder very much
about the the sort of veracity that this
is this is a real group um every time we
do a rally and blacks for trump people
are up behind trump
i get emails from people saying look
david the trump
campaign the trump team is known for
hiring people to go to rallies here's a
craigslist post of when they advertise i
get it i'm not ready to say the group is
totally made up there are black trump
supporters black trump supporters exist
i'm not gonna just say you know it it
just it seems problematic to to just
write off
a group
uh a minority group a historically
oppressed group and say what they
purport to be their political views
aren't real and clearly it's made up i'm
not gonna do that but there are real
questions about what exactly blacks for
trump is and and sort of what to what
extent it exists as an organization i
encourage you to look it up maybe at
some point we'll get some kind of more
definitive answer we have a great bonus
show for you today how do you get the
bonus show i wish i knew no i do know
you sign up at joinpakman.com
today on the bonus show we will talk
about the anti-vaxx push in the nba
actually seems to be working to push the
league around a little bit we'll talk
about lebron james saying i did what was
right for my family that was get
vaccinated we'll talk about other
players saying no
um we will talk about mail delivery
about to get permanently slower and more
expensive why
you could probably guess
and lastly following up on our monday
story a judge has ruled that new york
city can go forward with its vaccine
mandate for educators and staff in the
new york city school system all of those
stories and more will be on today's
bonus show
sign up at joinpackman.com
speak to you then